hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about how I build connections and
how you can to welcome everybody to
another edition of evans book episode 64
the book is still in pre-release we've
got 99 sales right now guys i really
appreciate the support we got a bump
that number up a little bit if every one
of you watch this video buy one book i
will have hit my goal of 3000 pre-sales
so please guys if you're buying one or
10 or 25 with different bonuses attached
I really appreciate that support let's
get this thing going so we can do more
work and help more entrepreneurs so
today I want to talk about though how I
increased my connections and how you can
- what you can learn from it the
founding theory the core principle is
making sure that you're adding value to
the people who are in your current
network the people that you know and I'm
the guy who started with no network
right I didn't have a mentor I didn't
have anybody that I could talk to I went
to my bank asking for help and advice
not just a loan like you need a loan no
I'm I need a mentor I need help I don't
know what I need so I'm starting from
literally Ground Zero and and how it
built up is really just understanding
the people who are around you what they
need what are they looking for what's
their big goal and how can you help
contribute it to it so as an example
this is all happen like in the past
couple weeks I had Lewis Howes on my
show as an interview and he has a
successful interview called the school
of greatness he's a YouTube channel of
podcast and afterwards I connected with
him to say hey Louis who do you want to
have on your channel like who's the
dream candidates that you want to have
on your channel and he listed off five
people or like Mike Tyson the rock
Will Smith a couple others and I don't
know any of those people not yet but one
of the things that I'm now trying to do
is connect with everybody who I know to
say hey do you guys know any of these
five people because I'm trying to help
out a buddy of mine and and I may not be
able to help him but if I can that's
gonna mean the world to Luis right these
are the five people on his dream list
that if I can help provide that for him
that's not like he's gonna owe me one
but he's gonna feel really good about me
gonna feel like I added a lot of value
to him and so the next time I try to
help somebody else that are trying to
help myself out Lewis is gonna want to
help me out because I helped him do some
big thing and he wanted to do in his
life in his business and so it's taking
that min tallying that approach to
everybody around you here's another
example somebody on my team really loves
Bernie Brown
Randy Brown is a great speaker on
vulnerability has a great TED talk I
think she's an author I'm trying to help
her get in contact with Bernie Brown I'm
trying to do some kind of interview with
brené Brown where she might be able to
join in on it ask a question something
because this is this is one of her
heroes right now and I'm a big fan of
Bernie but for honestly for all of these
people it doesn't really mean anything
to me people asked me I remember going
to New York City and Ryan holiday asked
me hey if I could help you get one
person in a channel who would it be
and the only name I could come up with
was Kanye West because I think that'd be
a funny interview but other than that I
don't I don't have anybody I wish I
could meet I don't have anybody we faked
an interview so I guess that's a good
thing
maybe maybe means I need to have other
goals on that part sidetrack so the
person my team really wants to connect
with Britta Brown and nobody in my
network knows brené Brown nobody like
friends of a friend knows Bernie brown
but there's a guy who's a youtuber who
has interviewed brené Brown and I have
an access to him and so I'm gonna be
meeting him I already got an email
introduction to him and after we get off
our interview I'm hopefully can provide
a lot of value to him and I could do
something else to help him or he wants
to go on yeah I asked him hey who do you
want to have on your youtube show and
see if I can figure out a way to help
him and then ask him hey I'd love to be
able to connect at brené Brown to do an
interview with her and they'd bring my
personal long at the same time that
youtuber that I'm gonna be interviewing
who knows Brene it's also somebody that
my agent is trying to get in touch with
and is trying to understand better what
he's all about and so I said hey can I
can I ask a question for you I'm gonna
be interviewing him is there something I
could find out for you and so I'm
providing value to him so I'm providing
value to my agent I'm providing value to
the youtuber I'm providing value to
Brene hopefully and providing value to
the person on my team who really wants
to meet her and so just constantly
thinking about the people in your
network and understanding what they want
to accomplish who they're trying to
connect with what they want to do and
try to figure out can you
help them or not you know I look inside
my salsa business two of the people that
I have on my team have spouses or
significant others who want to be
entrepreneurs who are entrepreneurs and
so that's an easy way for me to help
right like I want to help not just the
people on my team but the people around
them to write the their spouses their
securing others their parents to the
extent that I can like I can't help
everybody with everything but even if
you just open up the awareness of
understanding who the people on your
team and the people around you are and
thinking about what their goals are and
asking them what do you want to
accomplish trying to find ways to help
them you'll be surprised at how you can
help influence them getting what they
want in a lot of different ways and so
you know for the people on my team if if
their spouses and their significant
others really feel appreciated towards
me in what I'm doing then it's it makes
everything easier it makes their work
life balance easier makes it easier if
somebody needs to go above and beyond to
help out at the business because they
feel that personal connection where a
lot of times when you're working
somewhere you know the husband or wife
can see it as a negative because you
know they may be away from work at doing
some project but when if you can bring
them in it makes a lot easier and so
just taking that approach consistently
across everybody you meet everybody you
come in contact with to try to add value
try to help them understand their goals
and connect them with people that can
help them get to the next step that
comes back a hundredfold and so that's
how I built my connections from from
having from knowing zero of knowing
nobody to be able to connect with some
of the greatest thought leaders and
specially in the entrepreneurial world
that exists and so a super blast but I'm
not that smart and it's something that
you guys can do as well super easy to
follow you just have to take that
mindset with all the people that you're
talking to let's get to the book
questions
first up is a cookies room TV
congratulations I'm so happy for you
Evan you deserve it so much you're
changing the world thank you for that
means a lot I'm hesitating between by
now going in a British bookstore and
taking a selfie there haha so exciting
all the best feeling a lot of really
appreciate that the difference in terms
of buying now is one it really helps me
with pre-orders from the book stores so
that books so that you want to go and
take a selfie with
if they know that a lot of people from
your area in Britain are buying it
they're gonna stock more books where if
nobody's buying it pre-orders from your
area then they might stock one book so
that selfie may not be amazing cuz
there's only one book in the store
instead of 10 or 20 or 30 or more that
really helps me
it also helps get the book on the
bestseller list which can help fuel and
funnel the growth to even higher higher
heights even higher heights that works
if you really love the channel then do
both you can always order right now up
front and then you can pick up another
one and do a selfie when it comes into
the bookstore next up Thomas Johnson how
does the book payment process work so
that's pretty simple if you are ordering
one book then you can order from any of
the retailers that you're used to using
it from if you're Amazon or Barnes &
Noble or wherever you normally buy a
book most of those places have online
ability to bill the order and you can
find that find my book there and just
order however they accept payment
however Amazon accepts payment
processing that's how you can buy the
book if you're buying ten or more you
get a discounted price and the more you
buy the bigger discount you get and so
that we've negotiated a rate with a
company called CEO reads and so again
everything can be processed online if
you wanted to buy ten books on Amazon
you could it just it would cost you more
than if you use CEO reads so just giving
you guys options but whatever process
Andras on typically accepts that's how
most of them do it and you can make
payment through that
next up Manju Nath hey I've been excited
for your book will the book be available
in India means in Indian sites like
Amazon I n et cetera so if the book is
not this super important for you guys
watching the book is not available where
you are right now please let me know
leave in the comments so I can give that
to my publisher I'm know a lot of you
been asking about India obviously it's
not there yet but if you keep leaving
comments like this I can keep pushing it
to the publisher say hey let's get some
deals going with Amazon in yes we can
get it out next up Jason looking forward
to your book I want to point a copy my
family has a bit of a history in
publishing Inc would books and Tampa's
terrific independent bookstore if you
can get some copies I know they'll sell
best wishes looking forward to the
launch
I appreciate that Jason I am not really
handling too much on the retail side
since I'm going through a through
traditional publisher they're doing most
retail selling the thing that I know
that really helps again I talked about
before is if we get pre-orders from a
certain geographic area then it
dramatically increases the chance that
they're gonna want to buy more and take
up more so if you want me to get into
the inquit books in Tampa then the more
sales we have from Tampa the publisher
team can go to Inc wouldn't say listen
look at all these sales we have from
Tampa you guys got a stock this book and
the greater chance is that they will
next up is Janina can i preorder your
book in amazon that CA yes you can
Janina it still counts any any book sale
counts if you want for the pre-orders
and as well as the bonuses just make
sure again that you email in the
receipts a lot of you guys have ordered
but haven't emailed their receipts so we
can't really keep track of it cuz we
need to know the postal code or zip code
and you also get free bonuses and you
might get a free shout-out on a video so
make sure you email in the receipts
whenever you buy them je rise next I'd
love to see the audiobook version come
to life not really sure why it's got a
debut so late keep the pressure coming
guys keep the pressure for the audiobook
coming I send everything to the
publisher if you want in an area either
again a local area or you want it with
the audiobook let me know I forward
everything and it's gonna come out again
with the audiobook the feedback was
typically they don't allow pre-orders of
audiobooks but they're going to do it
for mine which is awesome but I want it
now I don't want to wait I don't know
when it's coming so the more pressure I
can give them the faster we're gonna get
it up so keep it coming in the comments
below
next up lucky n-- thanks evan your work
doesn't go unnoticed these videos are
part of my rigorous morning routine so
that really means a lot to me i take
great pride in that and also great
responsibility trying to create content
for you guys that you'll enjoy and i
think it also is important message for
other entrepreneurs for you guys
watching to create something that your
customers your audience would really
cherish and really care about you know
as an example i look at people who write
to me say how do i market my app how do
i market my app or where do I take
advertisers that are promoted we're
really you just need to create something
that people use like if people are
loading up their phone or tablet and
using your app on a daily basis ready
they come back every day to your app
it's gonna spread because people will
tell their friends as they oh what are
you playing or what are you using there
so if someone's coming once a month to
it they made
so you have to really increase the
quality of your production so for you
guys as entrepreneurs whatever it is
that you're making make it something
that somebody might put into their
morning routine as part of their regular
daily ritual to visit your website to
use your product to buy whatever it is
that you're selling something that they
can use on a regular basis the more you
can tie into somebody's routine and make
it that important that they would want
to consume your stuff daily if your
stuff is that important then it's gonna
spread it next up is Adam hi Evan thank
you for your assistance in backing I'm
getting information about their
likelihood to make your review or
summarized version of your book I hope
you good fortunes hey Adam a bunch of
people ready reached out to me about
channels who are doing book reviews and
and I've got already of people who've
created some pretty good summaries on my
channel you can go check them out I'm
not really in the book review business
I'll do I'll do some like highlighting
zuv books as motivational videos so I'm
sure those will come out and I'm excited
to see what people do with the content
and how they mix it up and kind of DJ it
to fit their needs and how people
interpret what I've created into
something but I am probably not gonna do
a summarized version myself I'll pull
out some like some specific chapters or
specific pages and read them as videos
and I have one coming out pretty soon
but I'm probably not gonna do a summary
edition of the book but I'm sure that
people will I'm excited to check those
out next up is Janina who writes in hi
thank you for being so humble and smart
oh yeah we need a party for believe
nation I'm in Toronto that's also HQ I
want to see how cute Jason is Jason's
got a fan club
Jason's smiling over to the side Jason's
got a fan club happenin here Janina
Janina wants to see how cute you are
Jason next up Antwon amazing love your
energy and enthusiasm and I finally
ordered my copy your book much love
Antwon really appreciate that it's gonna
be awesome keep up the good work and as
mentioned by others I'd love to see an
interview with people working from
behind the scenes like your manager and
literary agent publisher but also your
videographer Jason bring them on
while Jason's getting a lot of love you
guys got to do some serious arm to
because I've asked Jason to come on the
camera I don't know how many times and
he's like no no no no no so I don't what
do they have to do Jason to get you to
come on camera lay down the challenge
what's the gauntlet what do they have to
do to get you on camera
he doesn't know think about it you have
a week think about it people love Jason
next up ten more weeks Tamra bought 10
copies of the book really love you for
that Tamra we would very much like to
see an interview with Steve Nina and
Miriam we want Jason we want Jason Wow
the love is coming in strong for Jason
people really want Jason
next up Tanika yes we would love to see
Jason on the video thanks Evan it's been
fun getting a look behind the scenes of
getting your book out I'll be reserving
my copy for sure really appreciate that
Tanika and yes any arm-twisting that we
can add on Jason was amazing too let's
get him in I think I think he would do
really well I think you would do really
well we got to figure out a way to make
that happen next up is Nana
Ivan watch this video made watching your
videos look more real at least we get to
know you better perhaps a video where
you get to share some of your secrets
leading up to this point and about your
book publishing and videos would be
quite helpful I mean I've been doing
this video series for over 60 weeks and
I've been trying to share the behind the
scenes every week every week I've been
sharing what I've been going through how
I've been writing the book traditionally
now how I'm marking the book as well as
answering your questions so I'd
encourage you to go back on the channel
and look through we've got you got 60
plus weeks of content of all kind of
behind the scenes of what it takes to
create a book that goes with a major
publisher next up Herbert Einstein hey
yo greetings from Germany we want the
book let me pre-order on Amazon please I
love it another market I know some
people have ordered from Germany but I
guess they're running from amazon.com so
yeah again if there's a tree from a
country where you can't find it on your
local Amazon link that up and I'm gonna
tell the publisher so while we can apply
some pressure
next up eternal incantation how many
entrepreneurs businessmen successful
people did you study in your book
everything should mention about the
content table of the books a bit when I
see the t-shirt you're wearing and how
the cover name of the book is I don't
think it's worth ordering listen I
appreciate the honest feedback I'm also
not in the business of trying to
convince anybody of anything
like if you don't like the vibe I'm
putting off then you're probably not
going to like the book - right if you
don't like the messaging if you don't
like the t-shirt that I'm that I was
wearing with the different words on it
people love that t-shirt but if you
don't like it that's cool we might put a
table of contents up it might add some
some clarity to it but if you're making
your decision to buy the book based on
the table of contents and how many
people I've interviewed in the book it
probably won't be a good fit for you and
that's cool I don't want to try to
convince you to do something that you
don't want to do next up Katherine yes
the bonuses are awesome I've already
printed out some of the motivational
posters and I'm really enjoying the rest
awesome Katherine thank you for that
feedback the bonuses this is a guest a
good part of a being with the order now
I get that the book is still far away
December it's coming out but you get to
be able to get the bonuses almost
immediately we stay within one week uses
about 24 hours before you get the
bonuses coming to you and that you can
apply to your business immediately
whether you're buying one 10 25 books
there's a lot of different bonus options
for you to get while you wait for the
book to come out in December so I'm glad
that you're feeling the bonuses
Katherine and I really appreciate that
comment next up Kevin Palomo Jason in
the video we're trying Kevin we're
trying he's right next to me and every
time I see Jason calling them out and
he's smiling but we still need to figure
out what he needs what he needs to get
on camera we're working on it and last
up is baron I appreciate the realness I
feel like most people would hide or lie
about the number of books they've sold I
think most people do I think there's a
lot of secrecy about how the whole book
industry works that's you know when I
was trying to research it and find out
myself there wasn't a lot of content on
how to go through the process so I
thought I would document it for anybody
else who wanted to become an author with
the major publisher and what's the steps
were and what the frustrations were in
the ups and downs and so I tried to be
real throughout the whole process and
you know sometimes that hurts
but hopefully net-net it's a win for
everybody involved and so yeah I try to
update you guys with the numbers the
goal is to hit 3000 books on the
pre-orders right now we're at 99 you
know that's not anywhere close to where
I want to be hopefully we can hit that
goal with you guys and your support come
on believe they Shane let's get 3,000
books but yeah I mean the whole point of
the series is be as open and honest
awesome with you and answer questions
about the about the process that not
everybody is super happy about but I
feel that's right so I'm gonna do it so
I'm gonna call it a wrap there guys I
really appreciate the support I
appreciate all the love I'd love to know
what you think about the opening topic
about building connections and how I do
it and how you might be able to learn
from that or how you build connections
in your business and if you have any
comments questions about my book the
book writing process you just want to
make sure that Jason gets on the next
video drop it in the comments below and
I'll do my best to reply
next week thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe or whatever
you're one where it is and we will we'll
see you soon bye